that's the question at what age did you
figure out that spoilers alert
uh santa isn't real oh dude i i've like
went on like a
like an operation at like midnight to
like find out
so like the stealth music to prove to
them
that i knew what they were doing and i
found out i i found out accidentally
because i i think i was maybe like 10 or
and it was christmas night and i was
like [ __ ] i really need to pee i drank
too much
whatever and i got up in the middle of
the night my dad was like this next to
the tree
and he just called me right handed and
he's like all right son it's time you
found out
it's time it's time it's time you knew
the truth you got me kid
i i think i i know where because you
know i i
i did like a thorough sweep of the house
yeah
but you know a few days before i'm like
there'll be presents here if you know
yeah my theory is correct my hypothesis
couldn't find any presence in the house
and i was like
they must be hidden in the garage so i
was like all right i'll wait i'll wait
till
till midnight and on christmas until
they bring them in and
uh as a i well i slept right it was like
covert ops just pretending to sleep my
parents came in to check
out sleeping yeah and i i wasn't all
right so i don't remember the exact
age i found out like santa wasn't real
but i remember as a kid
i was like the smartest dumb kid
in existence because i i i was i would
like be figuring out all these like
logistics of how santa
could be able to send these presents
around because there would be there
would be years
where you know i wouldn't be at home so
i'd be like
how's santa going to figure out i ain't
hungry
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so so i went so
so
like we'd be staying at my cousin's
house right and the presents would still
be there even though we were staying at
my cousin's house no matter where we
were every year
and for some reason it just didn't click
to me as a kid
that santa wasn't real but but like
instead of just
realizing that santa wasn't real i was
in my head i was like
i was like yo so this is how santa knew
i was staying here so we went to our
house
didn't see i was there saw like the
notes that i left
somewhere or saw like the phone call
that i had with my cousin that we were
coming around to his house right so
that's how santa knew that i was staying
around my cousin's house
and i explained this to my parents at
the time and my parents were just like
yeah yeah you've you've figured it out
you got it you figured it out you've
just started
yeah oh [ __ ] hell i think i just
remember being like damn none of this
jesus stuff seemed to have happened
when i was 10 i was like i don't know if
this santa stops real cause none of this
other shit's happening i want i can't
try wine
did you ever do it like that i think
it's just like an american thing but did
you ever leave like the
the cookies and yeah we did milk yeah
really yeah we didn't do that yeah i
didn't do that yeah
i think so my dad just wanted food i saw
this brilliant uh reddit post stuff like
of like a dad being like so my son's
left uh
cookies and milk uh on on his bedside
table but
how do i tell him that santa is lactose
intolerant do i just drink the milk and
take the shits for my son
well do i leave it there and break his
heart i remember one time my dad was
like no no no connor santa likes beer
and then she drank it obviously because
he brought a cold one for himself
i'm just gonna be to my son i'm like did
you know that santa
loves gin and tonic santa likes an
espresso martini
leave a gin and tonic and maybe a cheese
platter your dad will
i mean santa will definitely double of
course
double shot santa doesn't like cookies
like brownies but like the special
yeah the special brownies they give
santa the special kind of special
brownies
santa loves g-fuel just put a cup of g
fuel next to your brand
i can't believe your dad did i said that
to you that is so big brain because he
just hit you one of the beers
because he knows that we'd believe it
like i i i believed that it wasn't real
but
i also was like maybe a little bit
there's a chance that someone's drinking
this
well i mean santa is a grown adult you
know he might he's working hard
and drinking but i mean that's okay